the Democrats embrace their socialist
heed incivility becomes the word of the
day and the Supreme Court strikes a
really harsh blow against public sector
unions I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
Wow lots and lots and lots of news today
and we'll get to all of it first I have
to remind you that on July 2nd we are
going to be having a special event and
it's going to be awesome we're going to
be having another episode of the
god-king Jeremy boring hosting The Daily
wire backstage and we're going to be
joined by Jordan Peterson celebrating
Independence Day a couple of days early
7:00 p.m. Eastern on July 2nd and
obviously it'll be Jeremy it'll be me
it'll be Jordan and then Andrew Clavin
and Michael Moses will be there as well
and we will look back on our country's
birth and look ahead to its future with
the world's most famous Canadian
subscribers we'll even be able to write
in live questions for us to answer on
the air and that again is Monday July
2nd 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific with
special guests Jordan Peterson you can
find our special live screen on Facebook
and YouTube so subscribe there and make
sure you subscribe it to the wire so you
can ask questions because let's face it
it's the only chance you're ever going
to have the actually ask Jordan Peterson
a question that he's going to answer
from you he's just too inundated so
become a member with us pay us and then
we'll get your questions with them
basically that's the pitch that I'm
making here so we'll get to the news in
just a second first I also want to
remind you that the economy is a
volatile place particularly when
President Trump is pushing tariffs that
could have significant impact on the
future of the US dollar if we ends up in
a trade war with China China owns an
enormous amount of American bonds if
they start selling those bonds on the
open market the value of the dollar is
going to drop relatively radically if
that should happen you will be very glad
that you invested in precious metals and
that is why you ought to be looking into
investing in precious metals at least a
little bit it's a hedge against
inflation a hedge against uncertainty
and my savings plan every savings plan
should include a level of
diversification and that includes gold
of course gold is a safe haven against
uncertainty the folks that I trust with
gold investment are the folks over at
Birch gold group they sell physical
precious metals for your own possession
they will ship metals directly to your
front door and right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can move
your eligible IRA or 401k into an IRA
backed by physical gold and silver and
again gold is a great hedge against
uncertainty in the market Birch gold has
a long-standing track record of
continued success thousands of satisfied
clients
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
you all know about Birch gold free info
kit but for a limited time they're doing
something even cooler qualified
purchases can earn up to an additional
10,000 dollars in precious metals for
free through July 31st so to find out if
your purchase will qualify con
Birch gold group right now go to
birchgold.com slash men to request that
free info kit on gold and when you speak
to a Birch gold rep make sure to mention
my name
that's birchgold.com slash man let them
know that I sent you and do it now
because the offer only runs until July
31st again qualified purchases can earn
up to an additional 10 grand in precious
metals for free terms and limitations do
apply ask your sales representative for
details that's birchgold.com /ban okay
so the big news of the day is the
Supreme Court has handed down a ruling
that's a serious serious damage to
public sector unions all across the
nation and the reason is because public
sector unions are awful okay we need to
explain a little bit about the
background of public sector unions and
why they are bad and how this corrupt
bargain works between public sector
unions and state governments as well as
the federal government so here's the way
that it usually works in order for you
to be certified as a public sector union
or as Union generally that is
negotiating on behalf of an entire block
an entire industry you have to be
certified by the National Labor
Relations Board the National Labor
Relations Board decides that your entire
industry now fits within a bargaining
unit and then if a majority of that
bargaining unit votes to join a union
then that union now represents the
entirety of that bargaining unit so
let's say that you are a welder and
you're contracting with the federal
government so the NLRB will determine
that you are part of a sector and that
sector can now be representative by the
afl-cio for example if they choose to if
half of the people in that unit choose
to join the afl-cio vote to be
represented by the Union then the Union
gets to represent that entire collective
bargaining unit against the federal or
state government that's the way this
typically works okay in the state of
Illinois they passed a law that permits
public employee union eyes if a majority
of the employees in a bargaining unit
vote to be represented by a union that
union is designated as the exclusive
representative of all the employees even
those who do not join now the way this
becomes very corrupt obviously is number
one public sector unions are a massive
drain on fiscal resources because they
are not bargaining with the boss of a
company if all the members of daily
water decided to unionize and then they
decided to bargain with us the
leadership at the company we have an
interest in bargaining against them we
have an interest in saving money you
have two adversarial sides and then they
come to an agreement because the growth
of the business as well as the the
necessity of paying workers what they
need we all want to get to the
same point but we're coming at it from
opposite sides if you're a member of a
public sector Union and you are
bargaining with legislators legislators
have no interest in saving money
legislators are much more interested in
making some sort of deal with the Union
such that the Union gets paid a lot of
money and then the Union then dumps a
bunch of money back into electing those
legislators again legislators don't care
because it ain't their money right there
are third parties it's your money and my
money that are being represented by
legislators so there's this corrupt
bargain that goes on where unions get
certified as a as a union and then they
go and bargain with a bunch of
legislators and then the legislators
hand them a bunch of money and those
unions take some of that money and they
pour it back into the campaign's of
those legislators to get them reelected
it's this very very corrupt cycle it's
happening California for decades while
Illinois has very similar law under the
under the Illinois law the real problem
is not just that the Union can be
certified on behalf of an entire
bargaining unit which again I have no
idea how that's even constitutional in
the first place the National Labor
Relations Act in my view is deeply
unconstitutional I do not see how I as
an individual worker should be co-opted
into the bargaining of a collective unit
right this is not legislation this is
not me voting for politicians who are
going to install a minimum wage this is
a group of people in my particular
sector who may not represent a majority
of the population voting for a a union
that is supposedly going to represent me
even though I don't want them
representing me it is the it is removing
my personal ability to bargain on my own
behalf for a better job or a better pay
or better raise it's removing that
ability from me on the basis of a vote
inside of a collective bargaining unit
decided by the federal or state
government and that seems to me deeply
unconstitutional in the first place but
even assuming that part's constitutional
the question before the Supreme Court
that was decided today was can all of
those people who did not actually want
to join the Union be forced to pay the
union so according to law in Illinois
only the Union may engage in collective
bargaining individual employees may not
be represented by another agent or
negotiate directly with their employer
so my rights have been removed right the
union itself is the only unit that can
now bargain with the government if I'm a
really good employee of the federal or
state government then I can't bargain
with my employer I can't go in and say I
want a raise because they already have a
union contract and violates the union
contract for them to give me a raise is
one of the reasons why teachers unions
terrible because great teachers can't
bargain with the school for higher pay
or for a raise and great schools can't
fire bad teachers because of these union
contracts non-members and this is the
part that is become controversial
non-members are required to pay what is
generally called an agency fee which is
a percentage of full union dues under
Abood versus Detroit which was a
decision made back in 1977 this fee may
cover union expenditures attributable to
those activities germane to the union's
collective bargaining activities but may
not cover the union's political and
ideological projects the problem of
course is that unions use this money in
fungible fashion it is it germane to
politics to push Democrats kind of is it
germane to the functioning of the union
to push particular legislators the
argument can certainly be made the union
sets the agency fee annually and then
sends non-members and notice explaining
the basis for the fee and the breakdown
of expenditures here in this particular
case it was 78% of full union dues okay
so to recapitulate there are several
issues that have to do with unions only
one was decided today so one issue
number one is should unions be given the
power to bargain collectively on the on
behalf of non-members I think the answer
should be no to that it seems to me that
unions can be just fine if everybody
wants to join the union in fact the
whole point of having a union is that
people want to join it but if you have
to kneecap people if you have these the
the government in order to force people
to be represented by a union I don't see
how that doesn't violate the
Constitution that was not what was it at
issue though even assuming that unions
have the capacity to represent people
who do not want to be members then there
was a law on the books in Illinois it's
in California it's in a bunch of other
states in the Union this law suggested
that even if I did not want to join the
Union but the union is now bargaining on
my behalf
I know am forced by the government to
pay that Union so the government now
becomes the enforcer for the Union you
see how corrupt this is the government
forces me to pay money to a union so the
Union can pay members of the government
to cut it a better deal
his is all deeply deeply corrupt so
there's a member of the Union who a non
member of the Union actually state
employee whose unit was represented by a
public sector union in Illinois and he
refused to join the Union because he
doesn't like a lot of its positions
including those taken in collective
bargaining and he was paying something
like five hundred bucks a year to this
Union even though he didn't want to join
the Union in the first place so the
Supreme Court
held today under the under the decision
written by Justice Alito and joined by
Kennedy and Gorsuch and Thomas Ben
Roberts this this decision held that
this part of the law is no longer
applicable that you cannot force
non-members of unions to pay union dues
which seems like an obvious thing I
didn't want to join the union why should
I be forced to pay the dues so the
counter-argument to that that's been
made by folks on the left is well what
happens when all the members of the
Union decided not to pay the Union they
decide they don't want to be represented
by the Union anymore because they don't
want to pay the union dues and they are
quote unquote free riders right now
they're getting benefits of Union of
union representation without having to
pay the fee and the answer to that is so
what so what the answer to that is then
the Union should do a better job of
earning its members loyalty and earning
its members money it shouldn't be the
government stepping in and forcing
people to pay the Union when you don't
want to pay the Union in the first place
so Justice Alito delivers the opinion of
the court and your rights under Illinois
law public employees are forced to
subsidize the Union even if they choose
not to join and strongly object to the
positions the Union takes in collective
bargaining and related activities we
conclude that this arrangement violates
the free speech rights of non-members by
compelling them to subsidize private
speech on matters of substantial public
concern and this of course is exactly
right and Justice Alito goes on to
explain why all of the the foolishness
that is being pushed by the by the left
on the on these Union issues is
unconstitutional is the First Amendment
made applicable to the States by the
Fourteenth Amendment forbids bridge
mints of the freedom of speech we've
held time and again that freedom of
speech quote includes both the right to
speak freely and the right to refrain
from speaking at all the right to eschew
association for expressive purposes is
likewise prohibited is likewise
protected as justice Jackson memorably
put it if there is any fixed star in our
constitutional constellation it is that
no official high or petty can prescribe
what shall be Orthodox and politics
nationalism religion or other matters of
opinion or for citizens to confess by
word or act their faith therein
compelling individuals to mouth support
for views they find objectionable
violates that Cardinal constitutional
command and in most context any such
efforts would be universally condemned
suppose for example the state of
Illinois required all residents to sign
a document expressing support for
particular set of positions on
controversial public issues say the
platform of one of the major political
parties no one we trust would seriously
argue that the First Amendment permits
the
perhaps because such compulsion so
plainly violates the Constitution most
of our free speech cases have involved
restrictions on what can be said rather
than the laws compelling speech but
measure to measure x' compelling speech
are at least as threatening and then
goes on to discuss the fact that these
unions are essentially compelling speech
he says that the dissent in this
particular case proposes that we apply
what amounts to a rational basis review
that is that we ask only whether a
government employer could reasonably
reasonably believe that the exaction of
agency fees serves his interest this
form of minimal scrutiny is foreign to
our free speech jurisprudence and we
reject it here ok so then they go
through the Abood decision which is a
1977 decision saying the state can
compel people to pay money to unions and
just Alito destroys it he says there
were basically two rationales that were
used by the court in Abood to suggest
that unions could actually be forced to
that non-union members could be forced
to pay agency fees okay argument number
one was labor peace right so what the
hell is labor peace can it's a stupid
argument in the first place labor peace
is apparently the idea that if you are
not forced to pay an agency fee to the
Union then you may instead go join
another Union and then that other Union
will be certified and a different Union
will be decertified and the answer to
that is so the hell what why should you
be locked into a union forever that's
idiotic
and alito to bunks that fully I'll
explain what Alito has to say in just a
second first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at black rifle coffee so
I'm very excited to have black rifle
coffee on board if you've ever found
yourself just wincing at the weak taste
of coffee from one of those left-leaning
corporate brands you know the kind that
says that you can use their bathroom for
free no matter how homeless you are or
whether you decide that you want to
actually buy a bubbly water or not well
then perhaps you ought to try black
rifle coffee okay the folks at black
rifle coffee they're a hardcore they're
politically incorrect and they are just
awesome founded by former Special
Operations that's black rifle delivers
the best roasts to order coffee directly
to your door it guarantees our getting
fresh premium coffee with every order it
has a particularly awesome spicing in
addition to great coffee and gear black
rifle has a coffee club that makes
things easy
that means no lines no running out just
great coffee shipwrights yards or every
month hassle-free I've talked to the
founders of black rifle coffee and it is
just spectacular I mean they these are
folks who do not care about political
correctness they say what they want they
say what they feel and not only that
they make awesome
Coffee plus when you joined their coffee
cup Club you'll receive discounts and
offers not available to other customers
not only does black rifle make one hell
of a cup of coffee they also give a
portion of their sales to veterans and
first responder causes so you can feel
good about buying coffee from them when
you choose black rifle you're choosing a
company that supports vets and serves
coffee and culture to those who love
America so check it out black rifle
coffee calm slash been receive 15% off
your order you won't regret it the
coffee's awesome the people are great
and you're supporting a great cause
black rifle coffee calm / Ben that's
black rifle coffee calm / ban for 15%
off again black rifle coffee calm / man
I love these guys check them out black
rifle coffee calm / ban okay so again
the argument that was being made by a
bunch of folks on the left is that we
have to prop up these unions because we
must have a labor peace okay there's no
such thing as labor peace labor labor
peace is called monopoly if you
suggested on the other side of the aisle
that employers should be able to get
together and decide wages because what
we really need is wage peace everybody
would understand that amounts to
collusion a monopoly but when a union
does it and the government props up that
union this is supposed to lead to labor
peace which is just ridiculous the only
capacity before unions to strike is when
they have a monopoly you want to destroy
the labor market all you have to do is
have monopolies of unions because then
those unions can walk off the job
particularly if they are contracted with
public sector with public sector
employers now you've seen this you've
actually seen police officers walk off
the job and firefighters walk off the
job which makes cities completely
unworkable you had sanitation strikes
they completely destroy cities basically
and all of this does not create labor
peace it creates labor warfare but the
left thinks that labor peace amounts to
labor should be forced into a position
of bargaining thanks to a union so
Justice Alito destroys this he says the
federal employment experience is
illustrative under federal law a union
chosen by a majority vote is designated
as the exclusive representative of all
the employees but federal law does not
permit agency fees nevertheless nearly a
million federal employees about 27
percent of the federal workforce are
union members the situation the postal
service is similar although permitted to
choose an exclusive representative
Postal Service employees are not
required to pay an agency fee at about
400,000 our union members so in other
words it is now undeniable the labor
peace can be readily achieved through
means significantly less restrictive
than the than the assessments of agency
fees okay so
labor pieces stupid argument then
there's the better argument the better
argument is the risk of Free Riders
right so this is the idea that you're
gonna benefit from the Union bargaining
on your behalf but you're not gonna pay
the Union so the Union doesn't make the
money but they're bargaining on your
behalf
supposedly out of the goodness of their
of their hearts so here is what Alito
says about that
he says respondents and some of the
Amika endorsed this reasoning contending
the agency fees are needed to prevent
non-members from enjoying the benefits
of union representation without
shouldering the cost petitioner is the
guy who's suing strenuously objects to
this free rider labor he argues he's not
a free rider on a bus headed for a
destination he wishes to reach but is
more like a person shanghaied for an
unwanted voyage in other words I didn't
want to join this Union I don't want
them bargaining on my behalf and now
you're forcing me to pay them so how the
hell am i a free rider I'm not to pay
them because I don't want to be part of
the Union if I could get away from the
Union I would do it okay and Alito says
and this is the telling point says
suppose that a particular group lobbies
or speaks out on behalf of what it
thinks are the needs of senior citizens
or veterans or physicians to take just a
few examples could the government
require that all seniors veterans or
doctors pay for that service even if
they object it has never been thought
that this is permissible and this of
course is exactly right right again just
because a group says that it speaks on
behalf of a broader group does not mean
that it should be able to leverage the
government into forcing those people to
pay that group now the left is going
nuts over this decision and in just a
second I'm gonna explain why it is that
the left is losing its mind over this
decision the left believes that this is
going to destroy public sector unions
maybe the left truly believes that this
decision now that people are not forced
to pay the union's is going to destroy
the public sector Union wholesale but
basically people will stop paying the
union's the unions will run out of money
and then the unions will no longer have
a monopoly on labor and it will destroy
the unions as they stand the answer that
is okay so really that's the answer
because it is forbidden to kneecap
people to force them to join a union
pointing the government gun at people
and forcing them to pay a union is no is
no better so if the unions can't provide
services and benefits that make people
want to join the union that is their
problem the truth is that the American
law in states in the federal level have
been stacked in favor of public sector
unions for a very long time and it has
corrupted our entire system of
government unions take more than 3.5
billion dollars a year from public
sector union members can they spend
billions of
a year on politics people are always
talking about money and politics on the
left then I was talking about these big
corporations ooh the evil corporations
that are spending money to lobby
politicians and giving money to
politicians you know folks like chanc
Eiger are constantly making this case
after taking millions of dollars from
outside funders to to prop up their
companies sure you know all of this is
it corporate money is bad we know
corporate money is bad but the truth is
the corporate money pales in comparison
to what public sector unions have been
spending on politics for a very long
time
unions spend a ton of money on politics
they spend a ton of money on politics
because they are bribing the public
officials with whom they will have to
bargain so when people are screaming and
crying about the union's not being able
to force people to pay the money
understand the reason they're upset
about this is because they believe that
people do not want to voluntarily join
unions if they wanted to voluntarily
join unions then they would go ahead and
voluntarily join unions now the way the
left is playing this is that the Supreme
Court in the last several days over the
course of several decisions the travel
ban decision and the religious freedom
decision that they are they are now
cutting against left-wing interest
groups what they're really cutting
against is non legal justification for
political ends right that's really what
the Supreme Court has done here the left
has this very perverse view of the
Supreme Court that the Supreme Court
exists to green light and and
rubber-stamp the leftist agenda that the
Supreme Court is there to benefit
particular populations of people that
the Left wishes to benefit so the Left
believes that in the travel ban case the
question is not whether the President
does have executive authority under
current law to actually use national
security as an excuse to shut down
immigration from five predominantly
Muslim countries and they say no no no
that's religious discrimination that
that's because Trump hates Muslims and
even though 92 percent of the world's
Muslims can still enter the United
States because they're not coming from
these particular countries this is
obviously because the Supreme Court like
president Trump hates Muslims it can't
be that the status of new law requires
them to actually look at the law it must
be they hate Muslims and then when it
comes to religious freedom it can't be
that the Supreme Court looked at the
status of the First Amendment and said
you cannot compel people to act in
artistic fashion on behalf of a group
that you like you can't do that by force
of government or they say no no that's
because the Supreme Court must hate gay
people and then when it comes to this
particular case it must be the Supreme
Court hates poor people the Supreme
Court hates you
the Supreme Court hates blue-collar
workers it can't be that the supreme
court looks at the First Amendment and
says how in the hell can you possibly
justify forcing someone at point of gun
to pay an organization they don't want
to join instead it must be they hate
unions and it's this sort of shortcut
thinking that leads to a breakdown in
civil politics in our society and get to
the civility in politics in just a
second because the Democrats are moving
radically to the left and it's happening
incredibly quickly but it is this
mentality that is leading to that
polarization every time the Left sees an
outcome from the right every time they
see an outcome that is based on law
based on neutral principles of law that
does not cut in their favor they
immediately attribute bad motivation to
the party that is pushing that
particular opinion so if I say that the
First Amendment suggests that you cannot
force me to join a union or you cannot
force me to be to pay fees into a union
their suggestion is I'm only saying that
because I hate blue collar people it's
always they go directly to the character
attack it's never that they stand and
say well you know maybe this person has
a little bit of justification for their
point of view maybe it is that they
believe in competing values like freedom
of speech above compelled payment to
collective bargaining they can't
actually credit the other side with any
sort of logic or decency instead they
immediately go to the Supreme Court as
filled with a bunch of bigots Justice
Gorsuch must be a bigot if only we had
Merrick garland there then it would have
voted in favor of our favorite
constituencies if you believe the about
that the the purpose of the Supreme
Court is to back your favorite
constituencies instead of to enforce the
law as it stands to adjudicate the law
as it stands then I would suggest that
you are perverting the cause of the
Supreme Court so at Alexander Hamilton
who wrote in the Federalist Papers that
the minute that the judiciary begins to
substitute will for judgments it loses
its raise on debt there's no reason for
it to exist in the first place so you
know the Supreme Court decision is quite
good and makes a lot of sense but the
left is not going to accept it because
the left has moved radically to the left
now just a second I'm gonna explain how
radically the left has moved I mean it
is pretty astonishing and we have some
more great evidence of that over the
last 24 hours first I want to tell you
about texture so if you're somebody who
loves information you listen to this
show so clearly you love information
clearly information is your thing well
then you really need to go and check out
texture because texture is the magazine
app so much great journalism is being
done
magazines these days the entire Harvey
Weinstein's scandals blown wide open by
Ronan Farrow over at the New Yorker the
Atlantic despite my did my disagreements
with a lot of what they put out the
Atlantic has some really interesting
long form journalism happening right now
there there are a lot of really great
magazines and it's across the board I
mean it's it's magazines in sports and
magazines in fashion you can get access
to 200 and top magazines all in one
place without buying a subscription to
any one of them individually it's the
must-have app for those looking to read
up on what's going on quality journalism
and great photos and the full archives
so go check it out right now my wife's a
big Reader's Digest fan she can get
Reader's Digest through the app which
means that she doesn't have to carry
around a copy of the magazine everywhere
she goes instead she's got it on her
phone to start your 7 day free trial go
to texture comm slash Ben that's texture
calm slash Ben why wait to start reading
the latest issues of your favorite
magazine instead get them right now try
texture for free today at texture comm
slash pen again texture comm slash pen
use that slash pens get your free trial
if you're an addict for information then
this is the place you're gonna want to
go texture calm slash man use that slash
pen let them know that we sent you so
when we talk about the radical move to
the left by the Democratic Party it is
obvious from yesterday's elections that
this is the case so yesterday a guy
named Joseph Crowley was ousted he was
expected to challenge Nancy Pelosi for
the speakership so how old is the
Democratic Party Nancy Pelosi is 78
years old Joe Crowley who is 58 years
old and he's just slightly younger than
my dad Joe Crowley was seen as the heir
apparent to Nancy Pelosi so he was the
up-and-comer he was the fresh face the
58 year old well he was ousted yesterday
in a Democratic primary - by a woman
named Alexandra Ocasio Cortes who's 28 a
first-time candidate and an open member
of the Democratic socialists of America
so she's a Bernie Sanders socialist and
she is a former bartender she's
bartending until about five minutes ago
she's a graduate of Boston College or
Boston University rather in 2011 and she
is wildly the left when I say she's a
leftist I mean she is an insane leftist
not only does she believe that Israel is
genocidal she also favors
medicare-for-all abolishing immigration
and customs enforcement she suggests
that there should be a job for everyone
provided by the government she believes
that there should be a minimum wage of
$15 she says quote when it comes to
power we can't just be tempted by power
and money alone what we need to do is be
bold enough and courageous enough to
choose leadership that takes no
corporate money
and advances healthcare education and
housing for all so this is another one
for programs is housing for all so she
is a full-scale redistribute of
socialist and she's really really
radical the reason that she won in the
district is because nobody came out to
vote only five percent of registered
voters eligible voters in this district
actually voted in this primary was on a
really weird day they're only a grand
total about twenty seven thousand votes
in the primary total she want about
seventeen thousand of those also Joe
Crowley did not take his district
particularly seriously he won 10
consecutive terms so he didn't spend any
time in that district nonetheless this
is the dawning of a new era for the
Democratic Party they've fully embraced
Bernie Sanders socialism and Maxine
Waters nuttiness here is this new hero
of the Democratic Party
Alexandra Ocasio Cortese here she was
today after winning the primary show
when the general to because this is a
heavily Democratic district claiming
that ice right immigrations and Customs
Enforcement is running black sites on
the border black sites being like CIA
sites set up in Jordan to torture people
she thinks that's what's happening on
the American border because she's a
crazy person I think that I it's right
there as a part of it it has baked in to
the structure of the agency and that is
why they're able to get away with black
you know with black sites out our border
with a separation of children we are we
are committing human rights abuses on
this border and separating children from
their families okay so one of the
reasons that Joe Crowley lost this
election also number one he wasn't
radical enough from the district but
number two one of the things that's been
happening in his districts is that his
moved so is now majority minority
district it's it's a heavily Hispanic
district and he was one of the last
remaining Democrats living in a heavily
minority district who was white guy so
there's been a real shift in racial
demographics in this particular district
and that was reflected in this election
as well she is a deep radical Alexandra
Ocasio Quinn says she will be treated as
an up-and-comer shall be treated as the
new heroine of the left of course
because she's a pretty young woman
obviously and also she is talented what
she does so I mean she's a good face for
the Democratic Party if you like
socialism if socialism their thing she's
a much more attractive candidate on
every possible level then Joe Crowley
except for the fact that she is a
radical insane person so here she is
talking some more in a debate about ice
and trying to go after Joe Crowley's
trying to suggest that that Joe Crowley
is not extreme enough on ice this
organization is as fascist as you have
called it I've said its face you have
said it's fascist then why don't you
adopt the stance to eliminate it this is
a moral problem and your response has
been to apply more paperwork to this
situation to have ice collect more
information on immigrants and that puts
our communities in danger and it also
conveys a profound misunderstanding of
how we should be approaching this
problem she wasn't the only radical who
was elected last night Ben Jealous who's
the former head of the n-double a-c-p
one Maryland's Democratic primary for
governor on Tuesday he promised to
deliver an agenda that makes College
free legalizes marijuana and raises the
state's minimum wage to $15 an hour so
the Bernie Sanders full on Medicare for
all
legalized marijuana raising the state's
minimum wage I don't care about the
legalizing marijuana all that much but
making college free and raising the
statement of my wage all of this stuff
is really radical stuff and you're
seeing a significant move a really heavy
move toward the the far left among
Democrats now that that clip that I just
played you of Alexandrine Ocasio cortes
showing righteous indignation against
Joe Crowley because he doesn't want to
abolish immigration and customs
enforcement because he doesn't want to
abolish the people who actually enforce
the border you know that sort of
righteous indignation is now what
animates the Democratic Party it makes
the Democratic Party feel special it
makes them feel as though they are
authentic this is one of the big
problems in American politics generally
right now and this is true right and
left is that people are mistaking
decency for in sincerity that if you are
a decent person and you don't want to go
after people hammer and tongs and you
are not demonstrating sufficient passion
that means that you are not authentic
really authentic people are people who
can't keep their emotions in check if
you're truly authentic you're the kind
of person who pounds the table right
you're the kind of person who looks
across at your opponent and yells at
them that's true authenticity and that's
how we know that you're a decent
authentic person and you're not just a
political phony is the more you yell and
the more you scream and the more
emotional you are the more we believe
the earn authentic human being well I
think that that is about as stupid a
policy as you can have when it comes to
voting for candidates unfortunately it's
being adopted on both sides of the aisle
but the Democrats have fully embraced
this stuff and they're moving radically
to the left politically as well
president Trump said yesterday the
Democrats have become the party of
Maxine Waters and Nancy Pelosi there's
no question
Pelosi is now the moderate in the
Democratic Party Nancy Pelosi is now
representing the moderate wing of the
Democratic Party because the
up-and-comers are all Bernie Sanders
acolytes good at one thing what's their
term resist it's the party of Maxine
Waters no no no no this has become the
party of Maxine Waters and Nancy Pelosi
that's all it is there's no question
he's correct about this of course that's
right
of course that's me now I'll say one
thing President Trump was not correct
about is that after Joe Crowley lost his
race last night President Trump tweeted
this out he tweeted out Wow big Trump
hater Congressman Joe Crowley who many
expected was going to take Nancy
Pelosi's place just lost his primary
election in other words he's out this is
a big one nobody saw happening perhaps
he should have been nicer and more
respectful to his president um pretty
solid guess that Joe Crowley did not
lose because he wasn't nice enough to
president Trump he lost to an open
Socialist who thinks Trump should be
he's not correct about that but he's
certainly right that Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes and the and the Maxine Waters
crowd these are the future of the
Democratic Party that's obvious his
Democratic Party has been radicalizing
for a long time you want to know where
Trump came from it's the radicalization
of the Democratic Party and the
reactionary nature of the right in
response to all of that now and talk in
in greater fashion about the the
exacerbation of this radicalization
among Democrats first you're gonna have
to go over to tell you we're calm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription as a Lee Weyer calm when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you get the rest of the Michael
Mostro live in the end of Clavin show
live plus when you become a subscriber
you also get to ask your questions to me
in the mailbag which we do every Friday
here on the bench Shapiro show and get
to ask questions when we do events like
the like the July 2nd broadcast we're
gonna be doing with Jordan Peterson gets
asked Jordan questions as well when
you're a subscriber plus you should go
over to YouTube or SoundCloud or iTunes
and subscribe there as well the annual
subscription by the way cost 99 bucks
and it brings you this as well the
leftist years hot or cold tumblr it
refills automatically every morning now
thanks to thanks to just the the state
of our politics plus when you subscribe
over at youtube or itunes then you get
in your inbox as soon as it comes in you
immediately have access to our sunday
specials which come out every Sunday
this Sunday special we are having on
Adam Carolla hey it's Adam Carolla
and make sure and watch the bench pair
of Sunday special this Sunday will all
be the guest we talk about carpentry and
me whizzing and sings that is accurate
so you can check that out when you go
and subscribe over at YouTube and and
subscribe over to iTunes as well we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the radicalism of the Democratic
Party has been in the works for quite a
while and it more evidence of this so
Keith Ellison who's currently the number
two at the DNC he nearly won the top
slot as head of the Democratic National
Committee he's a radical with with
long-standing connections to racist and
anti-semite Louis Farrakhan he came out
yesterday he compared the travel ban
decision by the Supreme Court saying the
president Trump has the authority in
fact to cut down on immigration from
countries that are that are heavily
ensconced in terror it includes five
Muslim countries but the countries that
the travel ban includes our North Korea
Syria Iran Yemen Somalia Libya Chad and
Venezuela right so not even all Muslim
countries he says that this is the
equivalent of the Dred Scott decision
Kay the Dred Scott decision said the
black people were not humans that's how
radical keith Ellison is when he makes
this comment it Supreme Court in the
1850s said that it was okay to own a
black person that was the Dred Scott
decision that decision hit the dustbin
of history so did Plessy versus Ferguson
so did Korematsu and this one will - I'm
telling you
discrimination and racism and hatred and
religious bigotry is never going to be
winning in the end now my favorite part
of that is that he says religious
bigotry and racism and hate from they'll
never win in the end except that he's a
giant Louis Farrakhan fan Jake Tapper
had on Keith Ellison yesterday and it
got really rough okay when you're too
far left for when Jake Tapper can
destroy you this easily because you're
this far left maybe your party has a
problem
here's keith Ellison - number two at the
DNC who by the way has worn shirts that
say I hate borders right the entire
Democratic Party has now embraced the
the consensus or at least large swaths
in the Democratic Party I don't want to
exaggerate large swathes of the
Democratic Party have embraced the idea
that every legal immigrants in the
country ought to be remanded out of
custody and released into the general
population they've moved far far far to
the left here's Jake Tapper going after
keith ellison for his associations with
lewis Farrakhan this is the number two
at the DNC post fact-checker did give
you four Pinocchios
about that that's as big they they were
wrong Jake they they I have no I have
not their think it's untrue Jake I'm
sorry and you know I'm just me that
that's why you called me on your show
today okay let's let's be real about
this
if any republican we're to have the sort
of associations that louis farrakhan has
they would be called out every single
day and every republican would be made
to disassociate from that republican as
well the democrats have moved radically
the left so far so that the incivility
of the Democratic Party as I said
yesterday I think that there are a
couple of people in the Democratic Party
who are trying to hold back the tide
Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi they've been
saying that incivility mob action this
stuff is inappropriate for Democrats to
pursue their the they're gonna hit the
dustbin of history those people are not
loved by their base their base is not
into it their base is Occupy Wall Street
their base is Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
slamming the desk and suggesting that
Isis running black sites that is their
base right now you can see this pretty
clearly Linda Sarsour for example she
goes after Chuck Schumer right Linda
Sarsour who has in the past supported
terrorists Linda Sarsour says that
civility is wrong and Chuck Schumer is
the problem what the King warned us
about people like Chuck Schumer he said
it's not the it wasn't the Ku Klux Klan
and the white citizen counselors who are
the obstacles towards justice it was the
people calling for quote civility and
people that were telling us when to
protest at what time and how to protest
okay so MLK according to Linda Sarsour
would oppose civility okay his protests
were not uncivil his protests were
protest there's a difference between a
protest and civil disobedience and you
going into a restaurant and shouting at
people until they leave and then
following them to another restaurant and
then shouting at them until they leave
but the left the hardcore left base
really believes this stuff they really
do right MSNBC's Chris Hayes who is not
on representative of the base he says
it's actually important to harass public
officials in a real deep sense like
hectoring yelling at public officials I
mean I covered all the tea party town
halls at 2009 that was a festival of
yelling of public officials and in the
same way that's actually an important
right to preserve okay that's that's not
true okay that just isn't true I went to
tea parties in 2009-2010 it was
generally protests that were held at
parks if they went to places with public
officials they were they were standing
outside like at the Capitol building and
they were yelling as public officials
came down steps they weren't going into
restaurants and yelling at people the
conflation of those two things is
astonishing but it shows you that the
Democratic Party has embraced it Sid
they really embraced their it this is
why Sarah Huckabee Sanders now requires
Secret Service protection they're a
bunch of members of the Trump
administration who now needs he
service protection specifically because
of the insanity of the left in all of us
here's some tape from yesterday that was
making the rounds Elaine Chao who's the
wife of Mitch McConnell she is coming
out of some sort of dinner party in a
private residence and she starts being
harassed by a bunch of protesters who
decided they're going to harass her
again if this were a bunch of Republican
men harassing Nancy Pelosi all we would
hear about is toxic masculinity for
three weeks but it's a bunch of
democratic men harassing harassing
Elaine Chao an Asian woman so we won't
hear about any of that plus I I mean I
guess we guess because they're Democrats
we can't assume their gender or anything
so here's the tape of that okay so
that's great yeah mobs who are standing
outside private residences now to harass
Mitch McConnell and Elaine Chao all of
this is gonna go really well I just
can't see how this goes bad in any way
civility is a thing of the past it's
been a thing of the past for a while so
people are blaming this on Trump people
are suggesting that Trump has
contributed to incivility all event the
Trump has contributed to incivility but
to pretend that Trump is the source of
incivility is to ignore the the last 20
years of American politics it just is
not accurate at all I remember Bush
Hitler I remember the left is describing
george w bush as a monster and in
genocide allah maniac I remember Barack
Obama suggesting that Mitt Romney was a
bad human being and that he Barack Obama
said to a group of CEOs that if that if
they didn't do what he wanted he's all
that stood between them and the
pitchforks and the torches that's
something that Barack Obama actually
said he's the guy who said bring a don't
bring a knife to a gunfight politically
speaking it was Joe Biden who suggested
that MIT Romney wanted to put y'all back
in Chains about a bunch of black folks
and all of this does not contribute to
an an era of civility but authenticity
is now connected deeply with incivility
the more authentic you are the more
uncivil you are this can't go anywhere
good so we are losing civility and we
are losing the concept of reasoned
politics in general instead we're just
supposed to shout at the moon about what
we wish politics would bring to us and
then magically it will descend upon us
right we've reached the when you wish
upon a star moment in America
politics so in just a second I'm
explaining what I mean by that the the
when you wish upon a star moment in
American politics is basically the
Pinocchio moment where when you wish
upon a star your dreams come true
all you have to do is shout at the moon
and all of your dreams will descend upon
you you can see this a little bit among
Republicans who believe that all of
their problems will immediately be
solved if President Trump simply does
what they want this is why there are so
many Republicans who are willing to go
along with president Trump's idiotic
tariffs but you see a lot more among
Democrats so among Democrats the idea is
if they shout at the moon and if they
wish the president Trump we're not
presidents and if they yell and if they
scream and if they make trouble and if
they confront public officials and if
they bang the table hard enough then
everything they want will magically come
to fruition okay this is not correct and
I don't Lee it's not correct it's not
good for our politics politics was
always about rational reasoned debate or
it should have been right this is what
the founders believed the founders
believed that it would be interest
juxtaposed against interest checking
interest and that the only way to hash
any of that stuff out was to have these
reasonable rational conversations those
reasonable rational conversations have
gone completely by the wayside in favor
of people screaming at the moon
the RNC just highlighted this among
Democrats that kind of really fantastic
at it's the best dad they've cut in
years regarding Democrats pushing
violence and extremism and here's what
it sounded like Kathy Griffin holding up
a stall of Trump I just don't even know
why there aren't uprisings of all of the
country
connecting the waters of course
[Music]
[Applause]
do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless
Samantha B is Michelle won't get rid of
Trump is a crashing economy I smell
money he's bring on the recession that's
Johnny Depp Madonna
[Music]
and then of course picture a Snoop Dogg
shooting an actor dressed as President
Trump and then the ad concludes the left
in 2018 unhinged all right this is a
it's a very good ad and it's also true
now I assume that the left could cut a
similar ad about people on the right
saying similarly ridiculous things
although I think that it wouldn't be
quite as prominent members of the right
saying such ridiculous things the
difference is that the Democrats have
claimed for a long time they're the nice
guys they're not the nice guys anymore
they've embraced their radical side and
what we are seeing is a complete shift
in the Democratic Party away from a
liberal party and sort of hard left
party that wants to restrict its
opponents that believes that the Supreme
Court should be a tool of its own
politics that believes that you should
be compelled to believe everything they
believe and believes that violence is
not necessarily out-of-bounds that is
going to go some really bad places okay
it's gonna lead to a reactionary side so
Laura Loomer who is kind of a nutty
human being in my perspective Laura
Loomer she confronted Maxine Waters now
I will say that I think that turnabout
is fair play when it comes to Maxine
Waters she's calling on people to be
pushed on I think that creating a
certain sense of mutually assured
destruction this is not the country we
want so you better figure this out that
that's not unwarranted so Laura Loomer
confronts Maxine Waters in public and
here's how Maxine Waters responds to
somebody doing to her exactly what she
has suggested be done to other
Republicans grinning as as Laura Loomis
pushed off the elevator but the irony
there is the matching Waters's why don't
you come up to my office and talk
civilly about it that's exactly what
Maxine Waters is telling people not to
do Maxine Waters is telling people not
to do that so when Laura Loomer does
that I I can't say the laurel bloomery
is wrong to do that when she is just
doing what Maxine Waters has
specifically asked her to do okay so all
of this is to say then what we are
watching right now is a polarization in
politics that simply is unhealthy and
it's going to get worse before it gets
better I don't think that this is
something we're on the verge of caring I
don't think a mass breakout of civility
is in the cards I just think that we're
too polarized as a country and we are
too in love with the idea that anger is
authenticity to let it go and certainly
it's not being helped by the by the
political situation we now find
ourselves in when judges are our ruler
the federal judge has now ordered the
Trump administration to basically
release all illegal immigrants as long
as our politics continues to be this
polarized there can't be any rational
discussion to be had at all okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate and then we'll do a
little Bible talk because it's Wednesday
and I do hope that a certain level of
judeo-christian values can return to our
public discourse so let's start with the
thing I like so this is really funny
Tracy Ullman
the comedian she did a little skit for
BBC in which she mocked leftist woek
leftist this is a woke leftist therapy
session and it's it's actually quite
funny how did you guys get on with the
homework by set you
guys isn't known especially inclusive
term not now change by homework do you
mean having to watch that old people
sitcom it's called friends lily and you
were supposed to watch it and enjoy it
well I try but I find it deeply
problematic why well there's the
homophobia the transphobia the fascism
and the slut-shaming and could Chandler
be any more annoying you can't go
through your 20s worrying about every
aspect of everything you have to pick
your battles and just remember that it
doesn't really matter because by the
time you hit your 30s most of you are
going to be massively right-wing anyway
have any of you started to think that
maybe poor people don't deserve benefits
no watch out for that one because that's
how it starts alibi understand this has
all been a bit much for some of you so
let's take five and have a whole mob I
find the word hobnob very phallocentric
even even some member I don't think
Tracey Ullman's a right winger okay even
members of the left are beginning to
recognize how crazy the left is this is
the good news if the good news is that
if there's a new consensus built it's
gonna be built on the back of the insane
so the insanity of some folks on on the
right the insanity of a huge swath of
left this is gonna drive a lot of people
to say you know what maybe you ought to
have rational conversations instead of
screaming and tweeting at each other at
least that's what I hope that's my
that's my hope is that we can have these
rational conversations because I think
that we can you know come to if we can't
come to consensus at least we can
clarify our positions through rational
conversation as opposed to getting up in
each other's grills shouting at each
other suggesting that because we
disagree on the nature of government
that means that were inherently bad
human beings I think that that can be
that
hopefully stop okay time for a couple of
things that I hate so I have to mention
if I'm talking about incivility and
stupidity on the left I also have to
mention it when it happens on the right
so Chris Cuomo of CNN he had on Steve
King representative King from Iowa whom
I know I think is personally a perfectly
nice human being but when it comes to
his politics I will say that he does
very stupid things politically on a
fairly regular basis and Chris Cuomo has
on Steve King Steve King had tweeted out
a Nazi sympathiser retweet on
immigration and Chris Cuomo confronts
him about it in here in Steve King's
response I don't believe that you
recognize his values as your own but you
say but I won't delete the tweet right I
don't get it I this brain is pretty
simple it's pretty simple I tweeted a
Breitbart story I didn't treat a message
from him I treated a bi tweeted a
Breitbart story I'm not deleting that
because then you all pile on me and say
King had to apologize he was wrong he
knows he's guilty I'm not I don't feel
guilty one bit I'm human I'm not here to
say that you are a neo-nazi okay that
you know me better than that
I'm here to say that you're so caught up
in this us versus them thing with the
left and the right that you don't want
to give ground on even something that
you acknowledge is wrong okay well
here's the truth what he should do is
delete the tweet and then you should
retweet the Breitbart story if that's
what he wants to do but you know check
the counts of people that you're
retweeting just don't don't don't be so
stupid that you retweet neo-nazi
accounts and then leave it up it's just
come on come on
okay other things that I hate so at a
rally this week president Trump went
went after Jimmy Fallon and Stephen
Colbert and Jimmy Kimmel as well and
these comedians decided that in order to
demonstrate that they were not biased
against President Trump and were in fact
comedians they would do a skit in which
they all combined to attack president
Trump so that this is great I mean it is
it is wonderful when comedians basically
acknowledge all of their own biases and
and justify everything President Trump
said about them it is also demonstrative
I think of the fact that all of these
comedians are so self-centered that they
feel the necessity to defend themselves
against the presidents of the United
States instead of just saying listen I'm
a comedian which is the actual proper
response to this instead
they're going to cut a video about
basically how much they dislike Trump
mocking Trump right back because this
look they're happy one from name checks
them it's their favorite thing what are
you oh I'm busy having no talent
did you see Trump's rally last night
nope really that doesn't sound like him
I heard he said we're all no talent
lowlife lost souls well that's not right
that's Conan hold on I'll get him oh hey
guys what's up Donald Trump the
real-estate guy who sells steaks he's
president yeah how's he doing
not so good hmm well guys give him time
okay and remember please be civil if
we're not careful this thing could start
to get ugly
hey how about start shaving my chest you
guys want to watch no thanks yeah what
you want to eat red man red hand okay so
there and there at the very end the
punchline of course is that they want to
go eat and a restaurant that through
Sarah Huckabee Sanders have yeah that's
that's not going to drive the the right
further into the arms of President Trump
that's not going to justify President
Trump just everything you said about you
and bringing the country together by
ripping the guy who you say is
politically biased and who says you are
politically by it's just brilliant stuff
from I mean honestly if that's the best
thing to come up with and the only funny
thing there is Conan then first of all
they should have left Conan in late
night let's be real about this Conan
with Conan was much better he's much
more talented than either of these other
two bombs okay time for a quick quick
Bible review so I've decided that
instead of haphazardly picking from the
Bible as I have been doing and now I
want to go through the Book of Psalms so
we're gonna pick a song every week and
we're gonna go through it so the first
Psalm is I think rather apt actually
this week it says blessed is the one who
does not step walk in step with the
wicked or stand in the way that sinners
take or sit in the company of mockers
but whose delight is in the law of the
Lord and who meditates on his law day
and night that person is like a tree
planted by streams of water
which yields its fruit in season and
whose leaf does not wither whatever they
do prospers it's not so the wicked
they're like chaff and the wind blows
them away therefore the wicked will not
stand in the judgment nor sinners in the
Assembly of the righteous for the Lord
watches over the ways of the righteous
but the way of the wicked leads to
destruction I'm not sure that one needs
all that much commentary but the
tribalism of our American politics has
become sitting in the company of mockers
standing in the way that sinners take
walking in step with the wicked if you
are following people who you know are
wicked if you are engaging in wicked
activity just because it is owning the
cons or owning the libs
you are not standing with the Lord you
are not standing with decency are not
standing with virtue you're standing
with a group of people put not your
faith in other human beings whose
variable standards of morality are going
to change with the times and in line
with their own particular proclivities
instead stand with truth stand with
virtue and you won't go wrong you won't
go wrong you'll haven't you know doesn't
mean you'll have a lot of company but it
does mean that you will be the the tree
that is planted by streams of water
rather than the chaff that is blown away
over time because standing with with
anything variable means that you're
likely to be blown away when the strong
winds come ok we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the latest I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing